when you get a script from guillermo is
it just an instant yes when guillermo
talks to me it's an instant yes i mean
pretty much
uh
yeah i mean i i love his work and i i
also know him a little bit and i've
heard him speak about cinema and that's
always very inspiring because he's very
articulate very passionate really knows
cinema both
emotionally and intellectually he's
really i i i love him uh
for that his ability to express well uh
talk about cinema um
and i love his movies so
if he wants me to do something as long
as i feel like i have something to
contribute uh like it's
uh
yeah like there's something for me to do
absolutely so i was very happy when he
asked me to do this um
and and the carnival world was also
something that
is a fantasy for me i mean i remember as
a child going to
side shows
when i was a kid and it
had a i remember them some of those
figures very specifically so what was it
like for you then day one when you walk
onto this fantastic carnival set
actually my first day was
me giving this speech about the geek in
a in a restaurant
so that was a little different but
the carnival was a complete world the
the production design is fantastic and
of course the cinematography is very
fantastic very juicy very luscious
lighting's very uh beautiful um it was a
complete world so when you walked
like
sometimes you'd arrive for a night shoot
you'd come in the car and you'd see the
lights because it was built out in the
country outside of toronto and you'd see
the lights and it was just thrilling to
enter that world and quite literally go
through the banners and then be on the
midway and see the characters and see
the the workers on the film working
around you know it was uh life imitating
art limiting art living and imitating
life you know it was all mixed up
because uh
there were so many uh similarities in
the world of uh
cinema to
this kind of uh
carnival life
and clem is just he's such an
interesting character because
he's so nurturing he's so caring when it
comes to his carnival and his carnival
family but then the way he treats the
geek is the opposite of that so how did
you view clem well yeah he does care for
his people he's just very uh pragmatic
and i think the way he views the geek is
he just sees
he's got a dark view of human nature and
i think he's got a dark view he sees the
world as a world of
predators and
and prey
and losers and winners and weak people
and strong people and he feels like
he's just taking
these people on the natural course of
things he he he doesn't own it he he
puts the responsibility on their
inability
to uh resist you know their desire for
uh
in this case through through alcohol or
or
opium you know uh he knows that can
bring someone down to an inhuman state
so he he accepts that that's the way it
is and he exploits that weakness to
have a life and to try to make a living
and also you can imagine that somewhere
in his head he feels like he's he's he's
an entertainer he's giving people
something he's giving them hope he's
giving them diversion he's making a buck
yes but he's also you know giving them
this uh
feeling of before the grace of god go i
because he's showing them these terrible
things and they're horrified but the
first thing the titillation and the
pleasure is partly based in the idea of
whoa i'm glad that's not me
so
yeah he's not uh he's not a nice person
but his code is very clear and he's not
deluded like a lot of the characters in
this movie he's very clear about who he
is and he's very honest about who he is
and i think it's interesting that the
one time that he really lets down his
guard and extends himself which is
central to the story because he kind of
takes in the bradley cooper character
stan and
teaches him things and brings him into
his family and essentially the guy
betrays him so
out of that weakness that tenderness
that thoughtfulness
he gets burned so that reinforces even
more his kind of pessimistic view about
the nature of uh kind of a dog-eat-dog
world and you gotta you gotta be tough
uh to survive
which makes sense uh
you know in a post-depression uh
you know working-class uh
ambience